This story is from when I was a senior
in high school. Back then, I was a
rebellious teenager, but only when it
came to my family. I was not a bad kid
by any means, just a punk when it came
to my family. I had a loving family, but
I was that kid who was too cool to spend
time with them. They always expected me
to entertain my little brother, Jake,
who was only 10 years old at the time of
the story. I was 8 years older than him.
With that age difference, we may as well
have been different species. Whenever we
would take trips, my family would
usually stay somewhere on or near the
ocean. We only lived about 5 hours from
the coast, so it was an easy trip. This
specific year, they decided to take a
trip to Maine. Don't get me wrong, it
was beautiful, and as an adult, I would
love to go back, but as an 18-year-old,
I thought that this was the worst trip
we could ever take. Before I continue
the story, let me just acknowledge that
I know how much of a piece of garbage I
was back then. Even as I write this, I
can't believe how much of a little punk
I was. We got to the house, and it was
incredible. It looked like something out
of a Stephen King novel, which was
fitting because we were in Maine. It was
a massive white house with green
shutters that was deep within the trees.
My dad even made the joke, "This is how
most horror movies start, isn't it?"
Probably not the best thing to say in
front of a 10-year-old. But my brother
didn't care. He was just as mesmerized
by the house as I was. Inside the house
was almost like a maze. The back center
of the house was a huge living room that
had an awesome view of a forest behind
the house. The rest of the house had all
these hallways that intersected in
places that strangely didn't make sense.
It was like a house you would design in
the Sims and not something you'd see in
real life. The weirdest part of this
place was not the hallways. It was that
the house connected to a small adjoining
house. The house where the owner of the
property we were staying at lived. His
name was Hugh. He was, let's say,
strange. He was tall and wore this very
old sweatstained bucket hat. His teeth
were very yellow, but it wasn't his
physical characteristics that stood out.
It was his personality. He was goofy and
loud, a bit eccentric even. He welcomed
my family and acted very friendly toward
us. He kept referring to how kind folks
from Maine were. My family's polite and
nodded along with him while he was
talking to them. He told us that he was
right next door if we needed anything
and other than that we wouldn't hear or
see him for the entire week. We weren't
thrilled about having this person
basically in the same house as us. But
there was nothing we could do now and we
just decided to make the best of it.
Well, my family decided to make the best
of it. I was being the worst and telling
my family that I wanted to leave. I was
looking for any excuse to leave and come
home. The first morning there, while we
were eating breakfast, my parents told
us that we were going on this great
hike. I told them that I didn't want to
go. After a little back and forth, they
decided to let me stay at the house, and
the three of them were going to go on
the hike. The main reason I didn't want
to go was that right before vacation, I
had just started dating this girl,
Danny, and I wanted to talk to her. I
knew if I went on the hike, I wouldn't
get service. So, I ditched my family to
text my high school girlfriend. I was
telling Danny about the house and
sending her pictures of the weird
layout. When I told her about the
adjoining house, she didn't believe me.
I told her I was going to send her a
video to prove it. At the end of one of
the hallways was a door. I sent her a
video telling her that behind that door
is Hugh's house. She still didn't
believe me, so I sent her a video.
I went to open the door assuming it
would be locked and it wasn't. The worst
part of this was that the door to Hughes
was right next to the door to my
bedroom. This guy's unlocked door that
was right next to where I would be
sleeping. I didn't love that. I ended up
walking inside Hugh's house while on
FaceTime with Danny. It was just a
normal little house. The room I was in
had a TV and a couch. Nothing
spectacular. I heard a door shut from
somewhere in the house, and I panicked
and ran back to our side of the house. A
few minutes later, Hugh was knocking at
the door. He was still cheerful and
goofy and asked why I was recording
videos of his house. I tried lying and
telling him that I was just lost, but he
didn't believe me. He also didn't seem
that mad. He told me that he had cameras
in his house and he got alerted to one
of the doors opening. When he checked
it, he had me on video flashing my phone
all over the room. I just told him the
truth after that and he laughed. He made
some weird comment about how nobody in
Maine locks their doors. I laughed
awkwardly and said I had to go. He left
and you better believe I locked the
door. Maybe people in Maine don't lock
their doors, but where I'm from, you
locked the doors and checked twice.
Danny told me that she didn't trust this
guy and that I needed to protect myself
just in case. I carried a large wooden
chair over to the door and basically
propped it against the door as a
makeshift lock. When my family came
back, I told them about the weird
interaction with Hugh, but they were
more angry with me that I went into his
house. They were right, but I still
yelled at them anyway. My parents had
only been back for maybe 30 or 40
minutes and told me to get ready because
we were going out for dinner. Again, I
protested and said I wasn't leaving. My
parents were still a little upset about
the Hugh thing, so they didn't bother
fighting with me. They told me that they
would bring food home for me. Not long
after they were gone, the sun went down.
I looked out the windows and it was
pitch black, like no light at all. A
couple of hours later, I was sitting on
the couch texting Danny when I heard a
loud crash.
I sprang up right away. It sounded like
it came from the end of the hall where
Hugh's door was locked. I started
putting pieces together in my head, and
I concluded that the sound very well
could have been the sound of the big
wooden chair being knocked over. My
first thought was that Hugh was trying
to get in. I snuck over to the hallway,
wanting to catch this creep in the axe.
It was too dark to see at the end of the
hall. I flipped the light switch and the
chair was knocked over and on the ground
next to the chair was a backpack. A
backpack that wasn't mine. I ran to the
screened in front porch, locked the door
that led to the inside of the house and
made sure the screen door to the outside
was locked. I know it's not exactly a
fortress, but it would at least give me
time to make a move if I needed to. I
sat in the fetal position on the ground
under a patio table. I didn't know what
to do. And of course, I left my phone in
the living room where I was texting
Danny. I heard footsteps coming from
inside the house. Not erratic movements,
just normal walking. I don't know
exactly how long had passed, but it was
at least several minutes when I saw the
headlight of my dad's van pulling in. I
got up, ran outside, and told them to
stay in the car. My parents were
confused because I was speaking
incoherently about what happened. That's
when Hugh came over, and I just about
fell on the ground.
He leaned over to my dad and said he
needed to talk to him in private. I
tried pulling my dad back, but he
basically just dismissed me. I could
tell by Hugh's body language that
something was wrong. He wasn't being
gleeful and silly anymore. He looked
like he had seen a ghost. My dad shook
Hugh's hand, turned to me, and told me
to get into the van. He said that we
needed to go somewhere quickly. My
little brother was confused, and I could
tell my dad was freaked out. My dad
drove away from the house and to the
grocery store parking lot about a mile
down the road. Just minutes later, we
saw several police cars drive by the
parking lot. We all started yelling at
my dad to tell us what was going on, and
he was honest with us and told us
everything. Hugh also heard the loud
noise. He got an alert that his camera
had been set off. The chair that I was
using as a lock must have had enough of
an impact on the door when it was
knocked over that it registered movement
on Hugh's camera. He assumed I was
trying to get inside his house again. He
thought that maybe I was trying to pull
some kind of high school prank. He
checked the cameras and didn't see
anything. He said he had a gut feeling
that something was wrong, so he decided
to invade our privacy and check the
camera that he had in the hallway of the
house we were staying in. It was too
dark to see anything until I turned the
light on. He still only saw the knocked
over chair in the backpack, which he
thought could be mine. Just as he was
about to turn the camera off, he saw a
tall, bald man come out of the bedroom I
was staying in. A man he knew wasn't my
dad and wasn't me. The man grabbed the
backpack and went back into the room.
Hugh ran outside immediately to help me
and noticed that's right when I had
locked the screen door and ducked down.
He was smart enough to assume that I
probably wouldn't have believed him. And
he was right. I wouldn't have. Instead,
Hugh hid in the front yard with a clear
vantage point of the house just in case
this intruder tried anything. He didn't
want to sneak in through the adjoining
house and potentially alert the intruder
because he thought that might put me in
danger. As soon as my family returned,
he told my dad everything and that's why
we ran off. We were only in the parking
lot for a few minutes when Hugh called
and said that the police chased the man
into the woods and they hadn't caught
him yet. He told us to remain there and
that he would grab all our things and
bring them to us.
We stayed at a hotel that night and
drove home the next morning. If I hadn't
acted like a spoiled kid and stayed at
the house, all this could have played
out much differently. It could have been
a lot worse. A few months later, my dad
reached out to Hugh and asked him if
they ever caught the guy. They never
did. Even with all Hugh's cameras around
the property, they still didn't know how
he got in or even what his intentions
were. He could have just been a homeless
man looking for shelter. At least that's
what I told myself back then so I could
sleep at night. Sometimes the scariest
things that happen to us aren't always
face tof face interactions.
Sometimes it's just people hiding in
plain sight.
Every year my family goes on this epic
vacation together. We stay at my aunt
and uncle's house that's right on the
ocean in West Palm Beach. Their son Will
is the same age as me, and we've always
been good friends. It's also not just my
immediate family. My other aunt and
uncle join us and bring their kids as
well. Their daughter Teresa is my best
friend. We went all through high school
together, and because we're the same
age, have the same last name, and kind
of resemble each other, everybody
thought we were twins. We would love
these family vacations because we would
tell strangers that we were twins. As we
got older, Teresa, Will, and I would
party like rock stars on these family
vacations. We would spend the day on the
beach with the family, but at night,
Will would take us to bars and clubs.
Because he was the local boy, he knew
all the hot spots. On one specific
family vacation from a few years ago,
the three of us witnessed something
weird, something that still bothers me
and freaks me out to this day. Teresa
and Will aren't so freaked out. They
think what we witnessed was some kind of
prank or just a weird occurrence. I'm
just not so sure. The trip was like any
other West Palm family vacation. We were
living it up. Once in a while on these
trips, Will would accidentally have a
little too much to drink. Maybe it
wasn't accidental. The boy liked his
drinks, but because of this, Teresa and
I would know exactly when he hit his
limits. That's usually when we would
call it a night and find a ride home. I
was always responsible for us getting
home. I would only drink to a certain
point and then spend the rest of the
time making sure that Teresa and
especially Will didn't end up in a ditch
somewhere. On this specific night, Will
started getting a little rowdy in one of
the bars. He kept saying that because he
was a local, he could run his mouth, but
that's not a thing. He was making a lot
of people inside the bar mad, and he
ended up getting thrown out of the bar
we were at. And I mean, he physically
got thrown out of the bar by the
bouncer. He was mumbling a little bit,
but he was fine. He didn't hit his head
or anything. I think his self-esteem was
hurt more than anything. I told Teresa
to watch him while I tried to find us an
Uber or another way home. He kept
calling me a buzzkill and that's kind of
how I knew it was time to go. I secured
us a ride that would be there shortly.
While we were waiting, I called my
boyfriend and just told him about the
night we were having. He laughed and
told me to call him when I got back to
the house. Just as I hung up the phone,
Teresa ran over to me freaking out. She
said she wasn't paying attention to Will
while she was on her phone, and he got
up and wandered off. The boy was in no
condition to wander anywhere. I tried
calling him, but his phone kept going
right to voicemail, which is right on
brand for Will. After a few minutes of
running around the streets yelling his
name, I heard Teresa shout at me that
she could see him. Thankfully, it was
Will. He was walking in a very crooked
line and heading towards the swamp or
forest or something. I don't know what
you would call it in Florida. I don't
know the difference between what
qualifies as a forest or a swamp. It was
a heavily wooded area with a lot of mud
and dirt. I'm going to refer to it in
the story as a swamp because I feel like
that's more on brand for Florida.
Anyway, Teresa grabbed him before we
entered the swamp and started giving him
a verbal beatdown. Will was laughing and
acting like a toddler. As soon as Teresa
let go of Will, he sprinted into the
swamp. I don't know if it was adrenaline
or rage, but without thinking, we
sprinted into the woods after him. It
only took us a little while to catch up.
He was so messed up that he wasn't
moving very fast. Using the flashlight
from the cell phone, we were able to see
just how dirty and gross this area was.
Our feet were completely covered in mud.
As we started heading out of the thick
brush, Will, of all people, told us to
shush. We both looked at him like we
were going to smash him in the face. And
before we could speak, he told us to be
quiet again. He ducked down and looked
scared. This was a completely different
Will than 10 seconds ago. It didn't take
us long to realize why Will got down. We
heard shouting and screaming coming from
somewhere in the swamp. It wasn't just
normal screaming. At least to me, it
didn't sound that way. It was like
screams I've never heard before, and I
haven't heard them since. The three of
us just stayed quiet and stayed put
while the sounds of these screams echoed
all around us. We couldn't tell exactly
where the screams were coming from, but
whoever was screaming sounded like they
were in trouble. Then, almost as
abruptly as they started, the screams
stopped. We didn't move. We stayed put
in that muddy swamp for at least another
15 minutes. Then, we sprinted out of the
swamp as fast as we could and made our
way back to one of the streets with the
bars. We got a ride home and sobered up
real quick. We tried figuring out what
we heard so we could make a rational
explanation. Anything we came up with
wasn't good. Teresa came up with the
idea to check out the swamp in the
morning. During the day, she said we
could safely navigate the area and see
if there was anything to be worried
about. I know I would never be able to
navigate my way back to exactly where we
were that night before. But Teresa's
good like that. She's like a
professional hiker, and she proved that
by getting us to the exact spot we were
hiding in the night before. All three of
our indents were still in the dirt from
where we were hiding. We all talked for
a little bit about what direction we
thought the screams came from, even
though it was hard to pinpoint because
of the way the scream echoed. We all
surprisingly agreed on the same general
direction. Teresa led the way through
the thick brush. This wasn't like a
normal path. We were basically walking
through bushes and mud puddles. A few
minutes later, Teresa gasped. On one of
the tree branches was the sleeve of a
denim jacket. Just the sleeve. On the
ground below the torn sleeve was a bunch
of different footprints in the mud,
almost like it was a struggle of some
kind. I was ready to go back, but Teresa
pushed forward a little bit. Not far
from the sleeve was a small opening
surrounded by trees. On the ground was
the rest of the denim jacket.
Surrounding the jacket were more of the
footprints in the mud that looked like
they were all bunched up in one spot.
Again, making me feel like a struggle
took place here. Leading away from the
jacket was one set of footprints. They
led straight into more thick brush where
it was impossible to track the footsteps
anymore. I was done with all of this. I
told Theresa and Will that I didn't feel
safe anymore and that I wanted to go
back to the house. They weren't as
freaked out as me, but they were uneasy
about all of this. We went back to the
house and I don't know why I let them
talk me into this, but we agreed to just
let it go. I was sure at that moment
that we had witnessed some form of
potential crime, but Will and Teresa
didn't fully agree. They said it was
possible, but most likely it was just a
joke, or even more likely a coincidence
that we found the code and just happened
to hear screaming the night before. Will
also convinced us that if we got law
enforcement involved, we would be the
only ones linked to the crime, if there
was one. And that scared us, even though
we clearly had nothing to hide. He made
the point that it's possible the cops
wouldn't believe three young adults were
just in the middle of this random swampy
area and witnessed a potential crime.
Would they really believe that our drunk
cousin just wandered into the swamp? If
I could do it over, I would have called
the police right after I heard the
screams. At the time, I just thought
Will made good points, and I thought it
was best to just move on and forget
about it. It's been several years now,
and I still think about that scream.
I've always wondered if I truly
witnessed a crime or if I just witnessed
some intense domestic issue. I'm happy
to get this story off my chest. It's
been therapeutic in a way to share this.
I hope nobody has to ever hear those
kinds of screams in your lifetime
because you'll never forget them.
This story I'm about to tell you
happened to my girlfriend and I last
summer. It was the first time we were
able to travel together as a couple, and
we were excited about it. She came with
me one time on a family vacation, but
that's not the same as being alone
together. So, this felt like a memorable
and important next step. The trip ended
up being memorable, but not for the
right reasons. Not that anyone will ever
find out who we are, but just in case,
for privacy sake, I'm going to refer to
my girlfriend as Vanessa in the story.
One important detail I need to point out
in the very beginning is that Vanessa
loves to remind me that I'm way too nice
and generous when it comes to meeting
people.
She claims there's a difference between
just being nice like a normal person and
being like my version of nice, which is
apparently treating every new person I
meet like they're my best friend. Those
are her words, not mine. I'm an overly
friendly guy, and that's gotten me into
trouble many times in my life, but only
once did it almost cost me dearly.
This story starts on the way down to
Ocean City, Maryland. It's a fun little
tourist town. It's basically just a
large coastal town with a ton of condos,
hotels, and restaurants. And it's all
right on the ocean for the most part. I
used to travel there with my family when
I was a kid, and this was the first time
I visited as an adult. When we were
about 20 minutes away from the condo we
would be staying at, I decided to pull
over at a gas station and fill up the
tank, as well as grab a few drinks.
While I was inside, a guy who later
introduced himself to me as Henry bumped
into me. He turned around and started
apologizing like crazy. I put my hands
up and assured him that it was
completely fine and probably my fault
anyway. Henry was a good-looking guy. He
was wearing a pink and black button-up
shirt and it was mostly unbuttoned.
He had kind eyes and he made direct eye
contact while we were talking. He was
probably in his late 20s if I had to
guess, but I don't know for sure. We
talked for a minute or two while we were
in line and I told him that we were
headed to Ocean City. He lit up and told
me that he and his girl were also
heading to Ocean City. I got excited and
told him the name of the condo that we
were staying at, and he smiled and said
he thinks he knows where that condo is,
and he's pretty sure that they're
located right near us. I was excited for
this genuine interaction. I get excited
meeting people and making friends. One
of my weaknesses is not being able to
see the flaws in people. I think it's a
strength, but Vanessa thinks it's a
weakness, even though she loves that
about me. Henry asked me to exchange
numbers and I did without hesitation. I
told him that I'd give him a call
sometime during the week and we could
link up at the beach or maybe grab
dinner one night. We gave each other a
bro hug and went our separate ways. When
I got back in the car, Vanessa knew
right away that I must have made a new
friend because of the way I was acting.
I told her the story and she just rolled
her eyes. We got to the condo that
afternoon and just had a relaxing
evening in the room that night. Our room
was on the fifth floor and it overlooked
the ocean. We sat on the balcony and
admired the view until we went to bed.
The next day, we went down to the beach
early. We're both early risers, so
getting up early is no issue. We set up
our chairs a little after 7:00 in the
morning and drank our coffee on the
beach. A few hours later, I heard
someone shout my name from behind me. I
turned around and Henry was waving at me
with a woman following him. She was not
like Henry. He was mirroring a lot of my
mannerisms and energy, and she looked
miserable. She was pale. Most of her
face was covered by these huge
sunglasses, and the rest was shaded by a
huge sun hat. She was also wearing
leggings and a button-up long-sleeved
shirt. She was also carrying this large
tote bag that looked empty. This was a
woman who did not like the sun. She
didn't say much. Henry introduced her as
his woman friend, Sarah, and she just
waved and gave an unenthusiastic smile.
She was the opposite of the Henry I met
the day before. After an awkward
introduction, Henry asked if they could
join us, and of course, we agreed. The
more the marrier was always my motto.
They didn't have chairs or beach gear.
Henry just plopped himself in the sand
while his woman friend stood there. I
got up and offered her my chair, and she
was hesitant for a second, but then took
the seat. While we were sitting there,
Henry told us they were staying in the
building that was directly next to ours.
My mind was blown. I couldn't even
believe the odds of that happening. That
was a major red flag for Vanessa, but
not for me. We hung out for another hour
or so and then went back to the room.
Before we left, Henry kept asking if we
could all go out tonight for a drink,
but I could tell Vanessa didn't want to,
so I just told him I'd call him if we
decided to go out. When we got back to
the room, Vanessa started to tell me
about all her concerns. She said that
Henry seemed fake and that he was giving
her major creep vibes. She also said
that Sarah was one of the rudest humans
she'd ever met. She complained about the
sun the entire time. She also made a
great point and said that she doesn't
know anyone who comes to a beach town
and hates the beach and then yet goes
down to the beach without bringing a
chair, a towel, an umbrella, or
anything. I told her she made great
points and that I wouldn't call Henry
the rest of the trip. The last thing I
wanted was to ruin Vanessa's vacation.
That night, I was sitting on the balcony
smoking a cigar, even though that wasn't
allowed. It was late, but I'm not sure
of the time. I was looking down on the
beach, and I swore I could see Sarah
down there walking alone. I mean, she
had the big tote bag, the big hat, and
the same outfit from earlier. I was just
too far away to be sure. I went back
inside and got ready to call it a night.
Vanessa was already in bed. I went to
make sure the door was locked and I
thought I could hear someone talking
coming from outside the door. This alone
wouldn't be concerning as there are
several condos on the floor, but the
talking sounded like it was coming from
right outside my condo. I tried to
listen, but it just sounded like
incoherent mumbling. I got close to the
door to check it was locked. And before
I could grab the door knob, I noticed it
shook as if someone was trying to open
it from the other side. Instead of
running or freaking out, I just politely
shouted that they had the wrong room. I
heard the sound of footsteps running
away after I said that. I had just
assumed that maybe somebody had
mistakenly tried to get into the wrong
room. After all, accidents happen. I
stayed awake a little longer just to
make sure I didn't have another surprise
guest. Nobody else came to the door, and
I went to sleep. The next day, the same
thing happened. Henry and Sarah
seemingly came out of nowhere and joined
us on the beach. They were wearing the
same clothes again. Normally, that
wouldn't be weird on the beach if you
were wearing a bathing suit or
something, but Henry and Sarah were not
wearing bathing suits. He was still
wearing the same outfit I saw him
wearing at the gas station, and she was
wearing the same outfit as the day
before. We didn't spend a lot of time at
the beach on this day. I could tell
Vanessa was all done with these two. I
politely told Henry that her and I were
going to go back to the room for a while
and then have a romantic dinner out. I
told him that I'd text him if we were
down to grab a drink later. He seemed
overly excited for some reason and let
us go. While we were getting ready to go
out, I looked out the balcony and I saw
Sarah standing on the ground where the
beach meets the patio of the condo
building. She wasn't facing the
building. She was facing the ocean. It
was weird that she was in front of our
building and not where they were
supposedly staying. But the weirdest
thing was that Henry was nowhere to be
found. She was by herself.
I watched her for a little while, which
made me feel like a creep. A few minutes
went by and Henry emerged from what
looked like the bottom of our building.
I watched him go over to Sarah. He
started waving his hands around and then
stormed off in the opposite direction
from where they were staying. Sarah
waited a few seconds and then followed
him. That whole interaction felt weird,
but who am I to judge? Once Vanessa was
ready, we left the condo and went out to
eat. While we were out, my phone kept
ringing. It was Henry. I didn't answer
it. After dinner, we started walking
back to the condo since we were only a
few blocks away. Henry called again.
Vanessa told me to just text him back
and tell him we're going to bed so he
stops calling. So, I texted him and said
that we were walking back from dinner
and that we were going to bed early.
Immediately, my phone started ringing.
It was Henry. I didn't answer. He
finally sent a message that said, "Hey
buddy, let's meet for a drink before you
get back. It's too early to go to bed."
Vanessa rolled her eyes and even I was
getting annoyed now. I responded with
another text that said, "Thanks for the
offer, but we're going to bed. We're
already about to be at the condo." Then
I got the weirdest text of all. A text
that may have had some other
implications.
All it said was, "Don't go to your room
yet." We both stopped and contemplated
the text while standing in the parking
lot of the condo. Henry was strange, but
was he capable of something malicious?
Vanessa thought so. We got to the room a
few minutes later and noticed that the
door was slightly open. I know for a
fact that I did not leave the door open.
Vanessa started to panic and she waited
in the hall. I slowly entered the room
and was relieved everything looked how
we left it, at least at first. Then I
started noticing things that weren't how
we left them. The balcony door was open,
but nobody was out there. In the
bedroom, both of our suitcases were
completely ransacked, and the only thing
missing was a pair of Jordans I brought,
Vanessa's bathing suit, and a picture of
us that we had printed out and left on
the dresser in the bedroom. We called
the police and told them that we thought
it might be Henry and Sarah who broke
into our room, but those were almost for
sure fake names. The condo next door had
no record of a Henry staying there. And
the only Sarah in the building was not
that Sarah. When they tried to track the
phone, it was no longer in service. The
local police told us that it's not
something that happens a lot in that
town, but occasionally some people will
try to rob tourists. We were just some
of the unlucky people who were chosen. I
guess the only thing I took from this
experience is that I really need to be
more careful about who I trust. And if
anyone out there visits Ocean City,
Maryland, just be careful because
somewhere out there, Henry and Sarah are
still lurking.